all perfectionism is is the 20-ton
shield that we carry around hoping that
it'll keep us from being hurt when in
truth what it does is it keeps us from
being seen I know in the absence of love
and belonging
there's always suffering that I know for
sure I've just never done anything
that's turned out to be valuable that
wasn't just scared was to do it need
motivation
she's Bernie Brown and here's my take on
her top ten rules a success volume to
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't be a perfectionist how many of
you struggle with perfectionism a little
bit okay so my favorite story is that
someone sent me an email one time that
said hey I know you have a book on shame
not so interested in that but when if
you ever write on perfection ISM I can't
wait so here's the here's the secret
when perfectionism is driving shame is
always riding shotgun and fear is the
annoying backseat driver
say it again when when perfectionism is
driving shame is always riding shotgun
we struggle with perfectionism in areas
where we feel most vulnerable to shame
does that make sense so we're all
comforting you have a little
perfectionistic which is code for like I
do things really well but I don't really
I'm not comfortable saying I have shame
perfectionism what is that I call it the
20-ton shield here's what perfectionism
really is it's a way of thinking that
says this if I look perfect live perfect
work perfect I can avoid or minimize
criticism blame and ridicule whoa that's
good all perfectionism is is the 20-ton
shield that we carry around hoping that
it'll keep us from being hurt when in
truth what it does is it keeps us from
being seen and so we had a great talk
about what's the difference between
perfectionism yes because somebody on my
staff had the nerve to tell me that I
was a perfectionist and I absolutely
deny that and you stood by me thank you
very much because I'm not perfectionist
I'm a person who strives for excellence
and requires excellence there there is a
difference is there not there is a
difference here's the difference because
sometimes I'm a healthy Stryver yeah and
sometimes I'm a perfectionist it depends
on if I'm feeling if I've got a
worthiness crunch going on so healthy
striving is internally focused its I
want to do this and be the best I can be
perfectionism is not about what I want
it's perfect
Chisholm is exactly what will people
think
rule number two find true belonging I
want to start with the Maya Angelou
quote quote that you share you are only
free when you realize you belong no
place you belong every place no place at
all the price is high the reward is
great let's dig in with what does true
belonging mean and why this message why
not you know Maya Angelou has been my
most steadfast counselor for my entire
life I discovered her probably thirty
years ago when I was in college
and I leaned into her work you know how
when you find those people that just are
unsparing and honest in their work but
they also bring you joy and comfort
she's that for me and I love everything
she does except for that quote that
quote has pissed me off for decades and
I never understood this idea that you're
free when you belong nowhere and as a
social scientist I know that belonging I
know this for sure like if you ask me
the one thing I know for sure two
hundred thousand pieces of data I know
in the absence of love and belonging
there's always suffering that I know for
sure so this quote from her about
belonging everywhere which is really
nowhere is what sets us free was so
troubling to me but then I started
digging in and I started trying to
understand what does it mean to belong
and I never thought of the concept of
belonging I thought belonging was like
we have a crew like like a posse or a
squad and in belonging to something you
kind of negotiate with external groups
of people but it's not what I found very
quickly is the rest of that actual quote
is part of an interview that she did
where she in it with bill moyers where
she ends up saying you know he ends up
pushing a little bit on and saying so
are you saying that you belong nowhere
and to no one and she said I belong to
Maya and what I found is that true
belonging is a spiritual practice and
it's about the ability to find
sacredness in both being a part of
something but also the courage to stand
alone and the people for those of us who
struggle to have the courage to stand
alone especially when we know that it
risk we're risking that sense of being a
part of something because we disagree
yes because we have a different opinion
because we love something different that
is the mark that's the mark of true
belonging to be able to say yes I am a
part of something bigger but I also will
stand alone when I need to and then then
it was like oh you belong everywhere in
nowhere and that is liberation rule
number three brave the wilderness I've
just never done anything that's turned
out to be valuable that wasn't just
scared was to do it like everything I've
ever done that's ever really made a
contribution I have felt alone in doing
it and afraid and but alive yeah that's
a really interesting gone good tell me
more about that alive alone but alive
but that's it's sort of like the
wilderness it is the wilderness because
you the metaphor for the book is let's
see if I get this right rather than
asking you am i right yeah that work
there's it's there's a poetic narrative
about its being wild and risky and you
have to prepare to go there and it's
also stunning and so there's an obvious
really clear connection between that and
putting yourself out there there's risks
and rewards and beauty but there's
interesting twist if if I get this right
that it's not that you are in the
wilderness
it's that you are the wilderness explain
that well I think what I what I have
found is that after the first time and
he only really takes one time the after
the first time that you opted to brave
their wilderness you pull away from what
a group of people thinks maybe it's your
maybe it's your creative community it's
your critics the first time you pull
away and find power and standing on your
own I think your heart is marked by the
wild I think you belong in into the
wilderness in a different way because
every time after that when you choose
fitting in over belonging to yourself
it's painful rule number four be
authentic when I talk when I do a lot of
leadership work I talk about understand
your personal values and my two personal
values or faith and courage
and said they say don't talk about faith
it's inappropriate it's this is a you
know an organic corporate corporation
and then I'll I do a lot of work in
churches and they'll say don't cuss and
so I just got to the point where I'm
like look I've said across from
thousands and thousands of people over
the last two decades of my life
listening to the hardest things you can
imagine and the two things that everyone
has in common when they're talking about
those things are cussing and praying if
you don't want me to cuss and you don't
want me to pray that's awesome ask
somebody else because what I'm not gonna
do is get up and bolt you and there are
a million people in this space who who
are better than I am who know different
things than I do
invite them if you need me to wear a
suit that's I totally get it I'm not
gonna do that
yeah yeah I'm gonna wear jeans and boots
and probably I'll wear a nice shirt yeah
but I'm not gonna do that because I
don't get up there when I speak in
public I don't get up there to talk to
my you know to talk from my Brooks
Brothers self to your Brooks Brothers
self I get up there and when I walk on
the stage I'm gonna talk about things
that ninety percent of the people in the
audience have never thought about talked
about and are scared to listen to and
they need to see me as a person and I'm
just that person I think that clear I
want if you invite me I want your event
or your leadership team I want it to be
successful yes you know and if you need
me to be someone different than Who I am
it's not going to be successful also if
you want to learn from other successful
women entrepreneurs check out my 2:54
girlboss series it's free the link to
join is in the description below we
think of vulnerability as a dark emotion
we think of it as the core of fear and
shame and grief and disappointment
uncertainty things that we do not want
to feel right I call perfectionism the
20-ton shield we carried around thing
and it's gonna protect us from being
hurt yeah but it protects us from being
seen rule number five embrace
vulnerability the biggest myth about
vulnerability is that it's weakness I
think a lot of people were raised to
believe that it was modeled I think
certainly in our culture
we see that a lot that to be vulnerable
to be open to be exposed is to be weak
and the truth is you know what I found
in my research is that vulnerability is
not weakness in fact I would argue that
it's our greatest measure of courage
when we went out and asked people what
is vulnerability we heard things like
vulnerability is the first date after my
divorce
vulnerability is starting my own company
vulnerability is taking responsibility
for something that went wrong at work
vulnerability is sitting with my wife
who has stage three breast cancer and
making plans for our young kids
vulnerability is taking my business
public you know the definition I use in
my work of vulnerability is simply
uncertainty risk and emotional exposure
vulnerability is about the willingness
to show up and to be seen even when
there are no guarantees and it's
interesting to me I mean one of the
things that I thought was really
interesting I gave a talk it's probably
a couple years now and it was being
translated by people doing American sign
language and they came up before the
talk started they said are there any
words that you're going to use a lot in
your talk that we should you know know
about that it might be different I said
well use the word vulnerability a lot
and they kind of there were two of them
they kind of looked each other they said
oh we do this for vulnerability and I
said what does that mean they said it
means weak in the knees and I'm like wow
that's not how I talk about
vulnerability and she said well there's
only one other sign for vulnerability
and I said what is it and she said and I
said oh that's what I'm talking about
and so to me vulnerability is our most
accurate measure of courage I mean it's
pretty powerful when I have 13,000
pieces of data collected over 12 years
that I cannot find a single incident or
story of courage that was not completely
underpinned by vulnerability I think the
problem arises that it's there's so many
little paradoxes with vulnerability and
one of them is that vulnerability is
courage in you but weakness and me when
I meet you it's the first thing I look
for in you but it's the last thing I
want to show you in me and so I think to
really put ourselves out there
knowing that if we do that enough we're
going to fail I just don't think it gets
more courageous than that
rule number six set boundaries I'm going
to tell you the story of how I get the
best definition of boundaries from a
creative kelly ray Roberts artist
Portland she's an artist to self train
she was an oncological social worker
like being a social worker and oncology
a hard work she taught herself to paint
now she has a thriving huge business and
she was teaching art classes and people
were copying her art and selling it and
selling it on Etsy and selling at
different places and one day she wrote a
blog post and it was about boundaries
and she said let me tell you what's okay
and what's not okay and she made a list
of everything that was okay it's okay if
you copy my art and hang it in your
house it's okay if you download one of
my paintings and use it as a little
sticker on your website as long as it's
attributed it's okay if you do this it's
okay if in good spirit you do this and
this it is not okay if you do the
following five things and it was the
most the clearest example and I called
it I'm like you just pulled some Social
Work magical on there and she goes yes
it would be so helpful if creatives were
all social workers because we're trained
and here's what's okay and what's not
okay you can come to my party love to
have you you can't get based yeah you
know and that's a hard conversation so I
think one of the reasons why or for
creatives the biggest thing I run into
and I work with creatives all the time
and interviewed them just almost
exclusively for rising strong is people
are afraid to put value on their work
so true people are afraid to charge for
it people are afraid to hey look I know
you're a really good photographer can
you come and shoot this wedding for ya
for nothing for $0 yeah first like a
freaky SH and you know whatever it's
your serving no because you know how
stressful it is when you can do you know
what happens when you get to wedding
they don't go up
I've never shot a wedding in my life
because the concept of the mother of the
bride is way more frightening to me then
Google like head of advertiser you know
I do it's like for the people who do
that that is it's a stressful and it
works right and so the answer is I'd
love to shoot the wedding this is my
view for doing that yeah oh man come on
I think I really love to but you know
because if you don't put value on your
work no one else will rule number seven
get rid of negativity negativity is
toxic
oh yeah bait ideas yeah we can talk
about different strategies but we will
not trust chalk people we will not trust
rock other programs like other business
know like let's keep it and it's amazing
how much forward progress and healthy
conversations and true growth can happen
when you take care of that safe space
yeah it's Jill Bolte Taylor who said
take responsibility for the energy you
bring into a room and I feel like what
people don't do online and social is
they don't take responsibility for the
energy they put out into the world and
in the worst case scenario what they're
putting out in the world is actually
disembodied from their identity there
it's anonymous yeah so I respond to
nothing it's anonymous so if you've got
some kind of flower icon and your name
is like Lily from sassy pants
yes I pants one two three I'm not
responding to you because you're not in
the arena you're not showing up you're
not being brave so I'm not gonna have a
conversation rule number eight don't
armor up I want to start with two
questions that I really want you to
think about and the two questions are
what should I be afraid of today and
who's to blame
[Music]
what should scare me and whose fault is
it to me these are the most profoundly
dangerous questions that we Center our
lives around and what they are
indicators to me what they're indicators
of is a culture of scarcity a culture of
not enough and when you think about
think about any milieu in your life
think about education what are we
supposed to be afraid of
and who's to blame politics the economy
social issues I guarantee you if you
turn on the news or open to paper today
the focus would be here's why you should
be afraid and here's whose fault it is
and it and what's interesting to me
about that is it's not just at a
cultural level or community level that
stuff happens in my house
every week every week with my husband I
talked to him about what we should what
should be you know why we should be
fearful and whose fault it is mostly
it's his but you know if something
doesn't go well at my daughter's school
then I'm like oh my god this is this is
gonna have huge implications for
University and we should be terrified
right now that she's not getting cursive
I know she's four but this is still
relevant it's indicative of scarcity so
let's talk about what scarcity culture
is and what it looks like scarcity
culture I think is best understood with
a simple question of never enough and
you can fill in the blanks never good
enough safe enough certain enough
perfect enough relevant enough and
perhaps I think one of the most
dangerous and insidious messages today
is never extraordinary enough somehow in
the world we live in today an ordinary
life has become synonymous with a
meaningless life and it has huge I mean
and I've watched it happen not only as a
researcher and they're qualitative
researcher so I
sit across from people and look in their
eyes and I have a good sense of what's
going on in their lives but as a
university professor who's been teaching
for the last 17 years it's been very
clear to me that extraordinary means
relevant and the top one is is the big
one for all of us personally never good
enough yeah which is shame which we all
have on occasion that sense that we're
not smart enough good enough perfect
enough loved enough promoted enough
we're not enough so what we do in
response to scarcity culture I think all
of us everyday is this we wake up in the
morning and we armor up and we we put it
on and we say I'm gonna go out in the
world I'm basically just gonna kick some
ass I'm not gonna let anyone see Who I
am
and in doing so I can protect myself
against the things that hurt the most
judgement criticism fear blame ridicule
I'm gonna armor up and I'm gonna be safe
and we rationalize and we convince
ourselves that this armor is really
smart and we use a lot of different
things to armor to perfectionism
intellectualizing but if you get really
really clear about what we're doing
every morning when we wake up and decide
to armor it's this simple this is what
we're protecting we're protecting being
hurt for a very simple reason that no
one really wants to talk about which is
this love belonging irreducible needs of
men women and children in the absence of
love and belonging
there is always suffering and so what we
believe is that we can protect our sense
of being lovable and being acceptable
and being worth connection with armor
here's the very worst news from my
research the news that above all other I
did not want to hear it's simply this
and I don't even want to say it cheeks I
think it's mean to say it but it's so
true and it's simply our capacity for
wholeheartedness can never be greater
than our willingness to be brokenhearted
which is a terrible thing but a truthful
thing that we can only love and be loved
as much as we are willing to have our
heart broken and so when we move through
the world like this in with our partners
with our children with our friends in
classrooms with the people who work for
us with the people we work for there are
tremendous casualties rule number nine
believe in your self-worth stop walking
through the world looking for evidence
that you're not enough because you will
always find it your self worth and your
belonging is not something that we
negotiate externally it's something we
carry in our wild hearts and if we spend
our lives looking everywhere we go for
evidence that I don't really belong in
this meeting I'm not really an artist I
just do this on the side and this is my
side hustle but it's not really my job
or we keep comparing ourselves you will
find exactly what you're looking for and
rule number ten the last one for a very
special bonus clip they show up what's
the greatest truth that you practice
regularly that you embrace in your daily
life a Michael one-hit wonder over here
but I have to say that it goes back to
be brave show up that's all that matters
thank you thank you I really mean it now
I've got a special bonus cut from Renee
on how to live wholeheartedly that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you just need to show up more number two
what negativity do you need to let go of
and number three where are you going to
stop being a perfectionist if i roughly
took the people I interviewed and
divided them into people who really have
a sense of worthiness that's what this
comes down to a sense of worthiness they
have a sense a strong sense of love and
belonging and folks who struggle for it
and folks who are always wondering if
they're good enough
there was only one variable that
separated the people who have a strong
sense of love and belonging and have a
straw and really struggle for it and
that was the people who have a strong
sense of love and belonging believe
they're worthy of love and belonging
that they believe they're worthy and to
me the hard part of the one thing that
keeps us out of connection is our fear
that we're not worthy of connection was
something that personally and
professionally I felt like I needed to
understand better so what I did is I
took all of the interviews where I saw
worthiness where I saw people living
that way and just looked at those what
do these people have in common and I
have I have a slight office supply
addiction but it's another talk so I had
a manila note but a new manila folder
and I had a sharpie and I was like what
am I gonna call this research and the
first words that came to my mind were
wholehearted these are kind of
wholehearted people living from this
deep sense of worthiness so I wrote at
the top of the manila folder and I
started looking at the data in fact I
did it first in this very four in a Ford
a very intensive data analysis where I
went back pulled these interviews pulled
the stories pulled the incidents what's
the what's the theme what's the pattern
it's my husband left town with the kids
because I always go into this kind of
Jackson Pollock crazy thing or I'm just
like writing and going and kind of just
in my researcher mode and so here's what
I found
what they had in common was a sense of
courage and I want to I want to I want
to separate courage and bravery for you
for a minute
courage the original definition of
courage when it first came into the
English language it's from the latin
word cur meaning heart and the original
definition was to tell the story of who
you are with your whole heart and so
these folks had very simply the courage
to be imperfect they had the compassion
to be kind to themselves first and then
to others because as it turns out we
can't practice compassion with other
people if we can't treat ourselves
kindly and the last was they had
connection and this was the hard part
as a result of authenticity they were
willing to let go of who they thought
they should be in order to be who they
were which is you have to absolutely do
that for connection the other thing that
they had in common was this they fully
embraced vulnerability they believed
that what made them vulnerable made them
beautiful they didn't talk about
vulnerability being comfortable nor did
they really talked about it being
excruciating as I had heard earlier in
the shame interviewing they just talked
about it being necessary they talked
about the willingness to say I love you
first the willingness to do something
where there are no guarantees the
willingness to breathe through waiting
for the doctor to call after your
mammogram they're willing to invest in a
relationship that may or may not work
out they thought this was fundamental
if you want more brunei check out the
first top 10 rules video i made on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there we think
of it as the core of fear and shame and
grief and disappointment uncertainty
things that we do not want to feel right